cuatro Estados Unidos ha pedido tomarse
los señalamientos rusos con muchísima
cautela es posible que el centro de
poder en Rusia no esté protegido frente
a un ataque de este tipo podría tratarse
quizás también de una operación de falsa
bandera Bueno hay todo es posible el
gobierno ucraniano niega que han sido
ellos pero de haber sido un ataque
ucraniano porque tendrían drones con el
alcance para ello los drones iraníes
chajín 136 que ha usado Rusia tiene un
alcance como de 900 y pico hasta dos mil
quinientos kilómetros y la distancia
Pues solo como medida de referencia
entre quiebre y Moscú es como de 770 por
allí kilómetros y y el objetivo craneal
no habría sido de haber sido ucraniano
el ataque no habría sido matar a Putin
ni causar mucha destrucción porque es
otro no es kamikaze no tiene mucha carga
explosiva Pero un golpe psicológico un
símbolo un ataque simbólico para
demostrar que el corazón ese poder de
Putin el kremlin es vulnerable un ataque
y que no pueden defenderse pues contra
ataques de drones kamikaze de ocurrir
claro según parece derribaron los dos
drones eh cuando estaban a punto de
impactar de haber sido Pues un ataque
Genuino ucraniano eran defensa de punta
que tiene los rusos allí para defender
el kremling Pero bueno se me recordaría
el ataque de los americanos con el
teniente colonial cuando tras Pearl
Harbor en la Segunda Guerra Mundial
lanzaron cuatro bombarderos del ejército
americano aéreo O sea no había fuerza
aérea pero el ejército de americano
aéreo desde el portaaviones contra Tokio
cuatro bombarderos creo que eran
bimotores pero la intención no era
destruir a Tokio era demostrar a Los
japoneses que les podían golpear tenían
la capacidad y subir la moral del pueblo
americano esa es una opción otra opción
es lo del falso positivo que ya pues
están no en Rusia que han intentado
asesinar a Putin que eso es un crimen
presidente de Rusia Aliado de Putin
decir pues que eso es un acto terrorista
y que hay que matar a selensky a su
gente al presidente ucraniano hay que
matarlo y voló que es presidente a la
duma venía a decir que insinuando que se
usen armas de destrucción masiva o sea
armas que destruyan no al régimen de de
kiev que podrían ser armas nucleares
tácticas y otra posibilidad que lo ha
dicho con Omar off o nores que había
sido de la duma rusa ucraniano Ruso y
ahora está exilado en Ucrania luchando
para Ucrania él ha dicho que podrían ser
elementos contra Putin que llevaron a
cabo el ataque otra posibilidad es para
justificar el hecho que viene una
derrota y ya parece que Putin está
repartiendo manuales se ha reportado en
que le instruya su funcionarios que le
digan instruyen al pueblo ruso Que se
preparen ante la posibilidad de una
derrota en
Claro pues ahí vendría el asunto del
ataque que pues no pueden contra Ucrania
No sí le quería preguntar sobre los
intereses que tendría el kremlin por que
ahora dicen que tienen derecho a
responder prácticamente nos ha
respondido usted a ello quería
preguntarle también que le interesaría
hacer lensky en ocultar este ataque si
realmente lo hubiera realizado Ucrania
Bueno claro el argumento es que Ucrania
no va a llevar a cabo ataques es lo que
dice el gobierno ucraniano celensky
ataques fuera de la fronteras que
solamente una guerra defensiva pero por
ejemplo esos ataques que ha habido
contra el tanque de combustible en
krasnodar Al otro lado del puente del
estrecho de kerch eso habría sido
ucraniano en suelo ruso ha habido
ferrocarriles incluyendo uno de petróleo
ruso por brians en Rusia en la frontera
cerca de Bielorrusia no de Ucrania que
han sido descarrilado O sea que han
habido operaciones de ataque que en lo
que sería territorio ruso no no en
crimea territorio ocupado así que ya
habría antecedentes no de ataque
ucranianos en suelo ruso pero claro pues
ese sería el argumento que Ucrania no es
una potencia ofensiva sino pues
solamente quiere liberar su territorio
pero claro no olvidemos es una guerra
total básicamente al menos para Ucrania